I am so glad that you guys are not five years
old!
If you were all in, like, kindergarten, the
only way I could teach you about your skeletal
system would be to sing you that stupid song.
You know, “The toe bone’s connected to
the foot bone, the foot bone’s connected
to the ankle bone...the ankle bone’s connected
to the leg bone.”
Like apparently there’s one leg bone.
For the purposes of teaching college-level
anatomy and physiology, let’s just say that
that song is … reductive.
Insufficient.
For that song to be at all useful for remembering
all 206 bones that make up your skeletal structure,
it would have to begin with something like:
“The distal phalanx is connected to the
middle phalanx …” and then end with something
like: “the frontal bone meets the parietal
bone along the coronal suture.”
And it would probably take like two and a
half hours to sing the whole thing.
But there is way more to know about your skeletal
system than just the names of the bones. In
addition to bones, there’s cartilage and fibrous
connective tissue that allows them to work together.
And maybe more importantly, if you’re going
to gonna talk about the physiology of your
skeleton, you have to talk about joints.
Joints are the meeting places between two or
more bones -- and even though it might not
sound mathematically possible, you actually have
more joints in your body than you have bones.
In a lot of places -- like your hands and
feet -- each individual bone is part of more
than one or two joints.
And then there’s the matter of what all
that bone, cartilage, connective tissue -- and
the joints that they form -- actually work
together to do.
And that is … move.
Body movements happen when muscles contract
across joints, moving one bone toward another.
And studying the different types of movements
your body is capable of, is not only pretty
fun, it’s also one of the best practical
ways to understand your bones and joints.
If you ask me, all of that is infinitely more
interesting than memorizing what goes where
and pretending like a “backbone” is really
an anatomical structure.
So. Aren’t you glad you’re a grown-up?
Dont worry, it’s not anyone you knew. It’s plastic, and
it’s a little bit smaller than the average adult skeleton.
But -- other than having me stand in front
of a giant x-ray machine for 10 straight minutes
-- I can’t think of a better way to walk you through
the major anatomical structures of your skeleton.
Now, if you managed to retain our introduction
to human bones last week, you’ll recall
that anatomists typically divide the skeleton
into two major parts: the axial and the appendicular.
The axial structure includes all 80 midline bones that
form your skull, vertebral column, and thoracic cage.
Starting at the top here, your skull’s eight
cranial and fourteen facial bones form your
body’s most complex bony structure, coming
together to do some pretty great things, like
protect your brain, help you see, smell, hear,
eat, and you know, have a face.
The 33 irregular bones in your vertebral column
start with your atlas vertebra -- the one that holds
up your skull, and is named for the Greek god Atlas,
who held the world on his shoulders as a punishment.
I’m not saying you’ve got a huge head or anything.
I’m just saying that’s what it’s called.
The vertebrae run down from your skull to
your pelvis, providing the central support
for your upper body and completing the enormously
important job of protecting your spinal cord
-- the main communication line between nearly
all of your body, and your brain.
Most of your vital organs are protected by
the 12 pairs of ribs and dagger-like sternum
that together comprise your thoracic cage,
which also provides attachment points for
your back, chest, shoulder, and neck muscles.
Now, the appendicular skeleton includes your
upper and lower limb appendages and pectoral
and pelvic girdles that attach to the axial
skeleton at the shoulder and the thigh.
And even though your arms and legs clearly
serve different functions -- unless you spend
a lot of time walking around on your hands
or picking stuff up with your feet -- both
sets of limbs share a similar set-up.
They’re each composed of three major segments
-- a common arrangement we see in loads of
animals all the way back to fish, which anatomists
refer to as “one bone, two bones, lots of
bones and digits.”
We can’t all be Dr. Seuss.
And that’s just about enough anatomy for
this plastic skeleton to pay for itself. I’d
rather focus on the physiology of the skeleton, and
in order to do that, we’ve got to talk about joints.
As is often the case in anatomy, we classify
joints both by what they’re made of, and by
what they do. Because form follows function, we can't
really talk about one without talking about the other.
So, the structural classification of your
bones is all about what kind of material binds
those bones together -- like, is it a fibrous tissue
or cartilage, or a special fluid-filled joint cavity.
But the functional classification focuses
on how much that joint can move.
So, for example, you have joints in your body
that don’t move at all. These include, say, the
joints between the bones that make up your cranium.
These non-moving joints are called synarthroses.
But you also have joints that move only slightly,
like the spot where your two pubic bones meet
to form your pelvis. That joint exists mainly
to absorb shock from walking and running,
but it also has proven very handy during things
like childbirth. These partly-moving joints
are called amphiarthroses.
Finally, there are the diarthroses, which
are fully movable, like your classic knee
and elbow joints. They’re mostly found in
your limbs.
But if you eventually find yourself in the
business of examining and treating people’s
joints -- and there are a lot of doctors who
do -- then it’ll be especially useful to
know the structural classifications.
Structurally speaking, you’ve got fibrous,
cartilaginous, and synovial joints.
Fibrous joints connect bones with dense fibrous
connective tissue, and are mostly immovable
-- like those sutures between your skull bones.
As you might guess, your cartilaginous joints
unite bones using cartilage, and are similar
to their fibrous brethren in that they don’t
move very much, and they lack a joint cavity.
But the family of joints that make all the
sports, and the entire art of breakdancing,
and yoga possible, are the freely movable
synovial joints.
Most joints in your body fall into this category.
Although they do make use of cartilage and
fibrous connective tissues like ligaments,
they’re different in that the bones they join
are separated by a fluid-filled joint cavity.
The cool thing about these cavities is that
they contain a bit of viscous, egg-white-like
synovial fluid that acts like grease on a
hinge.
Without that lubricant, just running down
the street could cause enough friction not
only to wear out your joint surfaces, but
actually overheat your joints enough to essentially
cook the surrounding tissue and leave your legs
smoking like a desperate Looney Tunes character.
These freely moveable synovial joints come
in six different configurations that together
allow pretty much any movement your body can make,
from a subtle head nod to a vigorous jumping jack.
All of which you will find in action at your
typical dance party.
Seriously, though, dance parties are an excellent
place to study skeletal physiology.
I mean let’s just take this from my perspective:
I’m at my high school prom. I’m wearing
a tux that is really uncomfortable and I’m feeling
kind of shy, standing on the edge of the crowd.
Maybe I want to test the waters out a little
bit with like a little hand dancing. Just
the hand going. Waving my hand from side to
side -- it’s a type of gliding movement,
one that occurs when one flat bone surface
glides over another.
All these motions use gliding, or plane joints,
like the one between the distal ends of your
radius and ulna, and the carpal bones of your
wrist.
But say after a while I feel like these gliding
movements just aren’t enough to fully express
myself. I have to enlist the more versatile
angular movements.
These are the types of motion that either
increase or decrease the angle between two
bones across any plane in the body, like if
I bob my head, or kick my leg up, or raise
the roof. If people still do that.
If that bending motion decreases the angle
of the joint and brings those bones together,
like when I bend my arm together, that movement
is called flexion.
When I bend it back, I’m increasing that
angle, and it’s called extension.
And if I continue that motion beyond my normal
anatomical positioning, and it’s somewhat
dangerous, that is called hyperextension.
These motions enlist the hinge joints. Similarly,
my oval-shaped condylar knuckle joints allow
my fingers to bend and ball up for a good
fist pump.
Now I’m getting super into it. I might like
raise my arms up over my head. Well, the act
of raising my arms away from my body is called
abduction, while moving them back down toward
the body is called adduction.
And this here, like, lasso movement? That’s
circumduction -- a combination of all five
of those movements that allow the forearm to move
in a circle while the elbow joint stays relatively stable.
Which really makes you wanna give credit to
those cowboys.
Now if you want to get really serious about
that lassoing and expand it enough to include
the entire arm, the move eventually will morph
from an angular movement to a rotational one
-- a motion that turns the bone around its
axis, in this case, the humerus.
Hip and shoulder joints use a ball-and-socket
design that allow rotational movement, but
the more flexible a joint is, the more unstable
and fragile it is -- which is one reason why
you see so many dislocated shoulders and hip
replacements.
And it’s worth pointing out that some movements
are just special and unique and weird, and
only occur in a few select joints -- especially
in your hands, feet, and jaw.
For example, your ability to touch your thumb
to your fingertips or give a thumbs up is
thanks to opposition movement, facilitated by your
saddle joint, which makes your thumbs opposable.
The pivot joint between your radius and ulna
allow you to rotate your palm forward or anteriorly
in a motion called supination, and turning
it backward or posteriorly is called pronation.
So that’s what I like to think is the more grown-up
approach to teaching you about your skeleton.
It did not involve any singing, but yes, a
little dancing.
And it was worth it, because you learned about
the basic structure of your skeletal system,
including the arrangements of both the axial
and the appendicular skeleton. And we went
over the structural and functional classifications
of your joints, along with the major types
of movement that they make possible.
Special thanks to our Headmaster of Learning
Thomas Frank for his support for Crash Course
and free education. This episode was co-sponsored by
Greg Avarbuch, Faht-Mah ikh-Bahl, and Ricky D. Shields.
Thank you to all of our Patreon patrons who
help make Crash Course possible through their
monthly contributions. If you like Crash Course
and want to help us make great new
videos like this one, you can check out patreon.com/crashcourse
Crash Course is filmed in the Doctor Cheryl
C. Kinney Crash Course Studio. This episode
was written by Kathleen Yale, edited by Blake
de Pastino, and our consultant, is Dr. Brandon
Jackson. Our director is Nicholas Jenkins,
the editor and script supervisor is Nicole
Sweeney, our sound designer is Michael Aranda,
and the graphics team is Thought Café.